hello and welcome to this video I am
tortoise is important that's Michael
plan Burke right yep I don't really
remember any games I've got a plus one
squat out of five games let's see what
we can do here in the brea again mostly
playing this based on on general
principles or then not concrete lines
okay interesting here you might go with
some a form so I'm going to reroute him
okay I'm closing things down don't mind
this tone too much hmm how to how to do
this here okay i can start with this
hmm doesn't he mind a for a little bit
at least okay
it doesn't seem to mind it at all ok I
have usually feel like trading some
trading heavy pieces helpful here for
black in this kind of situation kg5 I go
to the seven so this is mostly then it
is out of the way okay Querrey six or
not
can also go 97 g6 it's also an option
yeah to d7 or to be eight let's go back
okay so he probably wants to play h5 him
ok
he wants to go F for him soonish hmm
yeah my nights are not particularly well
placed to meet f for him
and the bishop won't be to actually just
make some sense IAM not looking good
okay after age six and I'm as boxed in
as you can be vit okay yeah just what it
is I didn't play it well and I have to
suffer now
still not clear that i'm losing here
because well it is reasonably close
disposition
they definitely will just shuffle now I
can only break through with some F form
I wonder if he takes on e5 I can
actually take with the f pawn Navy and
ready for Night at six it's not exactly
entertaining this shuffling back and
forth I wants to sacrifice on h6e em
shoot you might work let's see if it's
not working then I'm not in such bad
shape here Bishop g5 and Knight f6 here
we go
what time morning check white resigns
wow yeah winning this position is a bit
of a joke after he he completely killed
me then maybe it holds somehow but it's
just pretty terrible just pretty
terrible now this was badly played so
somewhere around here we're dealing with
the normal opening but yeah the way the
position got closed down was bad i think
probably probably around here as i have
to have to improve on my setup him if
I've might still be okay but here
somewhere here I have to do something
else I tried not to move anything on the
on the on the Kings side yeah maybe g6
there maybe g6 I don't know you don't
have to be in such bad shape on the King
side in this kind of position yeah I
think pawn to g6 this yeah this really
wasn't great it looks it looks terribly
threatening funny thing is that the
engine is on zero and doesn't it doesn't
have a very in the world which okay well
f-for is not so easily playable it wants
to play this and after night hdf5 play
g6
I have strong doubts about flex position
that it doesn't look loose it doesn't
look reliable at all okay we had this
and here i'm down to sit and wait yemen
yeah i'm not completely sure i think
normally you would imagine that white
has some kind of breakthrough him it
just looks too bad for black maybe it's
not the not super easy him yeah i can
really just sit and wait bring the night
to g4s interesting ok here now he took
it ok so after this he can definitely
sacrifice yeah that's clear and hear the
engine also says check that he can
sacrifice I only looked up to here and I
was thinking okay that might be due was
but no alternative anyway and I couldn't
see how wide wins the computer wants to
play rook f2 which is slightly
mysterious for me I for g74 possibly g7
so that this can be answered by g7 no
one that actually no clear up to two as
possible okay chance this and wins okay
now and that's pretty clear that what I
had I mean he had a very dominating
position and it's not very surprising
that night x h six would work yeah this
is this is all of a sudden the
a complete complete turnaround now I'm
winning after rook takes us all so
cringy five and this is hanging and I'm
straightening Knight f6 and his falling
apart Ian yeah this is what check yep I
don't know he probably he probably had
seen that 19th h6 um worked but just
after he played the other movement this
is often pretty fatal if you'll see that
you missed a big big wind or whatever um
yeah you're very irritated in in the
further course of the game okay thanks
for watching